on June 30th the world's media reported
on the death of three Israeli teenagers
who'd gone missing in the occupied West
Bank two weeks earlier but what else
happened there in June from June first
till the 11th a Palestinian man was
killed and 17 teenagers arrested by the
Israeli army on the 12th the three
Israeli teenagers go missing presumed
kidnapped Israel launches a massive
manhunt shutting down the occupied West
Bank over the next two weeks 10
Palestinians including two children are
shot dead or killed in air strikes over
1,000 buildings are rated more than 500
Palestinians are arrested dozens of
airstrikes are launched on Gaza after
the Israeli teenagers are found dead
Israel vows more attacks